the city's Muslim community is calling
on the NYPD this morning to investigate
an attack that happened outside a mosque
as a hate crime 59 year old Mohammed
Rashid Khan is now fighting rather for
his life after three young men beat him
as he was leaving a mosque in queens
village last week Khan has broken bones
in his face and fractured ribs as well
as a concussion he can't speak eat or
open his eyes
my uncle Islam bismillah alhamdulillah
Salam alaikum greenies a piece how many
hosts of the D show the first and one of
the only Islamic TV talk shows in
America going on five hundred episodes
strong al hamdulillah
and there are a lot of people spreading
misinformation about Islam a lot of
Islamophobia is growing and they're able
to in a matter of several years raise
almost a hundred million dollars for
what for a good purpose no for a noble
cause no for distorting the truth for
calling people away from peace
you know Islam calls people to peace to
have peace with their Creator peace with
themselves and peace with humanity so
creating this fear and anxiety in people
having people look at Islam as the other
have having people look at Islam as the
boogeyman that's coming to get you but
when people turn into the Deen show they
see this is absolutely not what we've
been seeing we have more of a chance of
dying from secondhand smoke we have more
of a chance getting bitten by a dog and
dying or getting get this getting killed
by our own furniture that's right so
people we need to get the facts out and
I'm gonna not we've been successful at
changing the perception that a lot of
people have and many people have
accepted this way of life and the work
continues
I've hummed it Allah so do your part can
contribute you know there are multi
billionaires out there with money just
overflowing from the bank accounts if
not multi billionaires you also have
multi millionaires with one cheque with
one click of a button they can finish
this campaign and it always helped when
the people who are doing the Dawa they
can have a clear and focused mindset
they don't have to
to worry about these secondary issues
they can just focus on what they're
doing and you have people out there who
are sponsoring so you know what I got
your back whatever it takes to keep this
going is done finished these are the
people that need to step forward and if
it's not contributing towards the D show
find an organization that is out there
promoting this piece promoting and
understanding edifying educating the
people about this Deen the fastest
growing Way of life in the world that's
right and support that cause so you have
a great opportunity here to contribute
and support the Deen show or any other
organization that you feel comfortable
with but do something do your part
get out there and share because if we
really care we're gonna go ahead and
share and this is my message to you
contribute if you haven't already helped
us to continue the work and inshallah
God willing we can move forward all
together and get the wonderful rewards
that the Creator has promised for those
who contribute towards the Dawa we'll
see you next time inshallah eating ba
Tech